[Music]
this is it your bachelorette weekend
what's on my head there's gonna be so
many hot Miami babes we're gonna be
swimming and dead girls hi Alice
Peter hi and get out of here she's mine
now yeah I'm getting too much trouble
okay yeah we don't get to see each other
a lot because we're all so busy with our
lives pickle what are you doing for work
these days well steena songwriter is the
drain potty clown is the reality but
this weekend's all about us
just like old times so everyone's that
does Panama
stop being a stupid [ __ ] con and you
love [ __ ] cocaine sorry I did a
little bit of it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get to the beam Micah feel special
[Applause]
[Music]
no no flips over and then will publicly
let's get rid of drugs nobody doing them
okay someone tell me what to do and I
will do it huh
my uncle's a lawyer should call him
first so what was your in Amsterdam
thank God just don't touch the body
what okay so actually we have already
moved him that could be up to 15 years
in prison
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
right flam or hi baby boy sleep now
oh no no no no
[Music]